the business of life continues in south
africa's capital city pretoria
despite a surge of infection caused by
the omicron variant
most people use masks and many people
keep their distance but very few are
panicking
and that includes the city's doctors
who've spent the past three weeks
dealing with omicron
covert patients do you expect them this
afternoon i've already seen two to go
with patients this morning okay
right symptoms
out
mild yeah
dr kutsia heads the south african
medical association
she's also a gp and describes the
previous wave caused by the delta
variant as a nightmare her surgery lost
10 patients
but this time it's different
what are you seeing
in terms of those people who are coming
through the door here at the surgery so
interesting enough um the people that we
are now seeing uh i i think after the
shock that there's a new variant and and
it's got 30 plus mutations whatever it
means to the average person out there
and then noticing that you know they
really don't get that sick and they're
happy and i'm happy they're happy are
you all happy because
really if you have been through delta
this is
totally totally different
most patients are reporting mild
symptoms like headaches and fatigue she
says
and people who've had a vaccine should
be protected against the most severe
forms of omicron according to a new
south african study
it says the two-dose pfizer vaccine
offers 70
protection against hospitalization
people are more likely to be infected
pfizer gives 33 protection on this but
adults are less likely to end up in
hospital admissions are down here 29
percent what is clear
is that vaccinated individuals are
experiencing milder infections in
general
and that's supported by the data
as for doctor
well she thinks boris johnson's take on
omicron is alarmist
the prime minister
definitely please don't don't just don't
say these type of things
don't
because that is hysteria
south africa's experience of omicron may
not translate abroad
but there is value in the real life
assessments that have been made here
john sparks sky news in pretoria